be real how many times have you imagined
getting that call from Kevin feige that
you're a superhero in the MCU I always
imagine I'm going to be cast as Spider
Gwen but hey that's just me back when
Rod got the legendary call for Ant-Man
Marvel wasn't as well known he kind of
felt like he was joining Dancing with
the Stars and actually he kind of was
once it came time for him to join all
the rest of the Avengers for civil war
he got roped into filming a big dance
number for the cast Paul Rudd met most
of the extended cast including Chris
Evans Jeremy Renner and Chadwick Boseman
by asking them to do a silly dance that
would be cut to the song We Go Together
from Greece honestly I would have paid
20 bucks to see that on IMAX instead of
quantumania oh do you yes really because
it didn't look like it for Mayan